[موسيقى]
نرحب بمشاهدين بمستمعي مونتي كارلو
الدوليه ترحيب خاص بضيوف البرنامج الذين
تشاهدونهم على الشاشه ويمكنكم ان تتفاعلوا
معهم على صفحتنا على فيسبوك
او على صفحه البرنامج على تويتر قبل ذكرى
الاولى من بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا هو
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني بلينكل
يؤكد ان الحكومه الصينيه تنوي تزويدا
روسيا بالسلاح لدعم الحرب التي تخوضها ضد
اوكرانيا هذا ما نفته بكين ووجهت بكيندارا
ووجهت الولايات المتحده انذارا الى
الصينيين اذا اقدمت بكين على هذه الخطوه
الخارجيه الصينيه نفد ذلك موضحه ان موقفها
هو التشجيع على السلام والحوار حتى كمل
هرس نائب الرئيس الامريكي اعربت في ميونخ
امام مؤتمر الامن عن مخاوفها من تعزيز
العلاقات بين روسيا والصين منذ بدايه
الحرب في اوكرانيا ماذا لو يدخل الصينيون
على خط الحرب الى اي حد هذه الخطوه هي خط
احمر مثل ما حضر الاتحاد الاوروبي سعيد
بان يكون معي في الاستوديو خطر ابو دياب
واستاذ حلقات دوليه سعيد بان تكون معنا من
بكين في ساعه متاخره سعاد باي شينا
وصحافيه صينيه وسعيد بان يكون معنا من
كوبنهاجن سامر الياس وهو كاتب وصحفي مختص
بالشان الروسي اهلا وسهلا بكم قبل ان نبدا
نعود ونذكر بما قاله انطوني
راينا شركات صينيه تقدم دعما غير في
التاكن لروسيا كي تستخدمه في اوكرانيا ما
يقلقنا حسب المعلومات المتوفره لدينا ان
الصينيين يخططون الان لتقديم دعم فتاك وقد
اوضحنا ان هذه المشكله خطيره وتؤثر على
علاقاتنا
وماذا قال ممثل السياسه الخارجيه للاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل
سيكون ذلك بمثابه خط احمر في علاقتنا
اخبرني السيد
انهم لن يفعلوا ذلك ولا يخططون للقيام به
لكننا سنبقى يقظين
نستمع الى رد المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الصينيه
الولايات المتحده وليست الصين من ترسل
الاسلحه الى ساحه المعركه نهج الصيني تجاه
قضيه اوكرانيا له هدف واحد وهو الحث على
السلام وتعزيز المحادثه
سعاد باي شي هو من بكين يعني لماذا عادت
الصين الى تعزيز العلاقات مع روسيا الى
هذا الحد منذ بدايه الحرب هل هذه
الاتهامات صحيحه ام لا
مساء الخير تحياتي للسيده ويا جميع ضيوفنا
الكرام اولا اريد ان اشير الى انه ان
العلاقات السينيه الروسيه تقوم ال هي يعني
علاقه
جيده ولكن يعني يمكن ان نلاحظ ان السينا
تطور علاقاتها
التابعيه مع روسيا هذا امر طبيعي ومهما
كان
بريهه ممات من بعض الدول الغربيه
وتعتزم الصين بتدوير علاقاتها مع روسيا
هذا يعتمد على سياسات الصينيه الخارجيه
المستقيله
والسلميه وايضا يمكن نلاحظ بشان امريكيه
بموقف الصين وتحللها مع روسيا اولا يجب
علينا ان نشير الى ان العلاقه بين السين
وروسيا تقوم على اساس عدم التحالف وان
العلاقه بينهما شراكه لكنها ليست من
التحالف ولا تستهدف الطرف الثالث وتلتزم
الصين بسياسات خارجيه مستقله
طيب اسمعي تفضلي
ولا تختاروا جانبا منا لجانبين للوقوف في
هذا الصراع وهذا لا يمكن ان يكون داري
لبعض الدول في اتهاماتها بسياسات سينيه
الخارجيه لان الصين هي دوله مستقله ولديها
حوريه لتدوير سياساتها الخارجيه مع اي
دوله من الدول على اساس المساواه واعلى
اساس الاعترام والمتبادل وهذا امر طبيعي
ولا يمكن ان تقبل لا يمكن لسان ان تقبل اي
اتهامات الخارجيه من الدول الاخرى بشان
على قارها علاقاتها التابعيه
وشرعيه مع روسيا طيب الكلام وضعك سامر
الياس يعني ماذا عن هذا التوقيت بالذات
وكيف يعني جاءت هذه الفكره
يتحدث بهذه الطريقه وان الصين تنوي تزويد
روسيا
بالسلاح وهذا الرد الصيني ايضا باتهام
واشنطن بانها تسعى الى سكب الزيت على
النار
تحيه طيبه لك للساده المشاهدين ولضيوف
الاكارم بدايه اعتقد بان الجانب الصيني
بنى علاقات جيده مع روسيا واستغل ظروف
الحرب والعقوبات الغربيه المفروضه على
روسيا وغير المسروخه في عددها وفي تاثيرها
من اجل تحسين اوضاعه الاقتصاديه ومن اجل
ان يكون طرفا قويا في المعادله مع في
علاقاته مع روسيا واتفق مع الضيقه بان
الصين ليست ذات علاقه استراتيجيه مع روسيا
هناك شراكه متطوره بين البلدين ولكن هناك
ايضا مناقصات كبيره تعيق قيام شراكه
استراتيجيه بين الطرفين ومشكلات كبيره
بالعوده الى السؤال اعتقد بان الجانب
الصيني ايضا طرح موضوعا للتفاوض والحوار
وحل الازمه بين روسيا واوكرانيا وهو ما
يخيف الجانب الامريكي ربما نظرا لان
الجانب الصيني يسعى الى حل سلمي بمش من
الاطراف الاوروبيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه على العكس من ذلك تماما تخشى من
تراجع الدعم الاوروبي للجانب الاوكراني
تراجع في دعم الاسلحه لاوكرانيا ولذلك هي
تسعى بشكل دائم ومتواصل من اجل شدشده
الاطراف الاوروبيه ان صح القول
وحثها على مواصله دعم اوكرانيا حتى
حتى تفلح اوكرانيا في ان تلحق هزيمه كبيره
بالجانب الروسي الذي تورط قبل عام بالدخول
الى اوكرانيا وانتهزت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الفرصه الجانب الامريكي لا يريد
للصين ان تدخل بشكل قوي على خط تسويه
سياسيه يمكن ان تشارك بها اطراف اوروبيه
هناك مصالح كبيره لدى الجانب الصيني مع
روسيا وهناك ايضا مصالح كبيره لدى الجانب
الصيني مع اوروبا والصين تخشى ايضا من
الهدف الاساسي للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وهو
التفرغ لاحقا في حال ضعفت روسيا وانهارت
للصين واقناع الاوروبيين بان الصين هي
الخطر الاكبر على الامن والاستقرار
لاوروبا ولولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهي
الخطر المقبل للناتو على الناتو طيب عندما
نقرا نفهم العديد من الاشياء وربما حتى
انطلاقا من تصريحات كما لها يعني هاجس
الولايات المتحده ان تساعد الصين روسيا
على الالتفاف على العقوبات وهذا هو ما
يخيف الولايات المتحده
التحيات لك استاذ توفيق وللفريق العمل
والمحاورين الكرام وكل من يتابعنا
ويشاهدنا يعني على ابواب
الذكرى الاولى للحرب للحرب يمكن الان
القول في جرده اوليه
ان من هم الذين كسبوا
الذين كسبوهم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والصين
واوكرانيا دمرت روسيا في وضع صعب واوروبا
ايضا من الخاسرين اذا
الصين من هنا الولايات المتحده تعلم جيدا
وهذا هدف استراتيجي الولايات المتحده منذ
فتره بعيده هو كما قالت المحاوره الكريمه
من الصين الا تنتقل العلاقه من التنسيق
والشراكه الى التحالف يعني الهدف هو عدم
حصول ثنائيه روسيه صينيه لانها تكون مهدده
في التوازنات الدوليه
والصين ولو انها قبل الحرب وقعت على بيان
مع الرئيس بوتين يتكلم عن شراكه من دون
حدود لكن في الحسابات الاستراتيجيه
الصينيه الدخول الى بلد اخر
يمكن ان يكون يعني يمكن ان يكون سابقا
وبالنسبه لها حتى اللحظه تحاول تحاشي كل
ما يسمى اساليب او حرب الفضه وتحتفظ
باساليب الحرب الناعمه حتى تصل ربما في
لحظه ما الاستعداد الكامل من هنا ربما من
الاهداف المخفيه لهذه الحرب الهجينه
والمتعدده الاوجه التي تدور في مجابهه
عالميه حول اوكرانيا
توجيه رساله للصين ومنع الصين اذا من هذه
العلاقه مع روسيا
وهنا نحن امام
عشيه اسابيع حاسمه سيحاول الطرف الروسي ان
يقوم بهجوم واسع في الربيع ويحاول يعني
تحسين اوضاعه في استكمال السيطره على
الدومباس بينما الجانب الاوروبي الذي
يستعجل الان في ارسال الدبابات واليوم
اثره زياره بايدن كان مطروحا مساله ارسال
الطائرات المقاتله كل ذلك هو من اجل يعني
ترك النزاع في اوكرانيا تحت السيطره
بالقياده الامريكيه ولذا ليس هناك نعم من
اثباتات بان الصين ستصلح لكن حصل هذا من
قبل يعني منذ مارس 2022 الولايات المتحده
تحذر الصين لماذا لان هناك ترابط بين
الاقتصادين الروسي والصيني الى حد ان
روسيا مثلا متحمسه للاستغناء عن الدولار
كعمله اساسيه بينما الصين اليوان مرتبط
كثيرا
بالدولار الامريكي اذا هناك نوع من مصالح
اقتصاديه مشتركه ان كان بين الاوروبيين
والصين او بين الامريكيين والصين والصين
التي تخطط لتكون الاقتصاد الاول في اخر
هذا العقد لا تريد الان التراجع لان
اقتصادها ايضا منذ ك حتى اليوم تراجع وهذا
للمره الاولى منذ فتره طويله من هنا لكل
طرف حساباته ولكن في هذا الموضوع السيد
بلنكن كما الجانب الامريكي بعد مساله
المنطاد وبعد التوتر في تايوان هو الان في
مجابهه مع الصين لكن يريد حصرها في مواضيع
معينه لان هناك قطبيه ثنائيه عالميه تشكلت
القطبيه الثنائيه هي امريكيه صينيه ولذلك
الان من كوريا الشماليه التي تحرك
صواريخها الى تايوان وحتى ايران التي
وصلها السلاح الروسي المتطور وكان ابراهيم
رئيسي منذ فتره في الصين كل هذا يعني اننا
امام انقسام عالمي حاد وايضا الرساله
للصين تمثل رساله تسميه الدوائر الغربيه
اليوم
الجنوب الشامل او الجنوب الكلي من اجل
البقاء بعيده عن المغامره الع سكريه في
اوكرانيا طيب سعاد بايشن طبعا تفاعل تفاعل
معك خطار ابو دياب فيما يتعلق بالانتقال
من علاقه عاديه الى التحالف الهاجس الان
بالنسبه للامرين الامريكيين برايك هو ان
تتحول الصين الى قوه كبيره يمكن لها ان
تستقطب العديد من الدول من حولها وتهدد
هذه الهيمنه الامريكيه
اعتقد اولا ولد او شيرا الى ان السن هو
طبعا تشهد تدهور متواصلا وخاصه خلال حياتك
السنوات وتعمل حاليا على تطوير
بلادها او تدويرها وتدوير كمياتها
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
حتى من اجل تحقيقه من اجل بناء الدوله
حديده اشتراكيه حتى عام 2035 مثل ما ذكر
مؤتمر
الحزب الوطني العشرين في
اكتوبر الماضي وهذا هدفها الوطني لا
يتحقيق تنميتها الاقتصاديه هذا لا شك ولكن
يمكن ان نلاحظ ان السينا
تدهورها المتواصل بعد يعني خاصه خلال هذه
السنوات هذا يعتمد على تنميه ذاتيه ويمكن
ان نلاحظ
تنميه الاقتصاديه الصينيه هي شاهده تتطورا
اكبر من معظم الدول العالم
وايضا يمكن ان نلاحظ ان السينا اكدت زي
مختلفه المناسبات انها انها تسعى الى
تطوير علاقاتها
وتعايشها السلمي مع الولايات المتحده لان
هذه العلاقه مهمه جدا بنسبه لكل منه
الجانبين وعاد للعالم
فتعايش السلمي بين الصين والولايات
المتحده هذا يعني مفيده لكل شعبين الصين
والامريكي ولكن كما يمكن ان نلاحظ ان زينا
اكدت ايضا انها لا تخاف منا تحديدات
الناجئه التهديدات المفروضه من الدول
الغربيه ومن من وتحديدا ضمن الولايات
المتحده لانها الدوله مست قله لن تقبل
وتلتزم بي تعدديه لن تقبل اي سياسات القوه
ولا حيمان واعتقد هذا هو موقف
سامر الياس هل تعتقد بان روسيا وانت الذي
تعرف الوضع الروسي بحاجه الى هذا الغطاء
الصيني
الجانب الروسي طبعا بحاجه للصين باكثر من
موضوع حاليا بعد قرار اوروبا الاستراتيجي
بالاستغناء عن مصادر الطاقه الروسيه النفط
والغاز بشكل اساسي المخرج الوحيد بالنسبه
لروسيا لانقاذ اقتصادها والتعويض عن
الخسائر الكبيره هو اللجوء الى الصين كاكا
اكبر
كتاني اكبر اقتصاد في العالم والاقتصادي
الذي يحتاج الى كميات كبيره من الطاقه
ولذلك وجدنا ان روسيا بدات بالتوجه شرقا
في شكل مبكر ولكنها الان تزيد هذه الخطى
من اجل زياده الصادرات من النفط من النفط
والغاز الى الصين نظرا لان الجانب
الاوروبي كان هو اكبر مشتري للغاز عبر
الانابيب والنفط من الروسي لذلك الجانب
الروسي بحاجه بشكل كبير اقتصاديا الى
روسيا الجانب العسكري اعتقد بان الصين لن
تنسق مع الجانب التركي الروسي وتدعمه
بانواع من الاسلحه حتى ولو طلبت روسيا ذلك
واضح تماما بان هناك محددات لدى الجانب
الصيني رغم كل التحالف وكل الحديث عن دعم
الصين لروسيا فانها رفضت فكره ان يكون
هناك لجوء للاستخدام السلاح النووي على
سبيل المثال وهي ايضا حاولت المحافظه على
علاقات جيده بالنسبه للموضوع الاقتصادي
اذا سمحت دعني اعلق على موضوع واحد الجانب
الروسي يسعى الى تطوير العلاقات
الاقتصاديه والصين ايضا لها علاقات
اقتصاديه جيده وتبادل تجاري كبير مع روسيا
ولكن التبادل التجاري مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هو اكبر بسبع مرات من التبادل
التجاري مع روسيا وكذلك العلاقات بين
الصين والاتحاد الاوروبي هي اكبر بكثير
على سبيل التبادل التجاري مما هو عليه مع
الجانب الروسي الجانب الاخر هو ان روسيا
يمكن ان تحصل الصين يمكن ان تحصل على
مصادر نفط رخيصه وهي الان من البلدان
العربيه واي
من روسيا بعدما بعد الحزمه التاسعه من
العقوبات
وايران بطبيعه الحال التي ستزيد انتاجها
في حال تم رفع العقوبات اذا مصادر الطاقه
بالنسبه للصين مؤمنه من اسيا الوسطى من
روسيا من من ايران ولكن بالنسبه لروسيا لا
يوجد بديل لها الا بيع نفوتها وغازها الا
الى الصين او الهند او الدخول في معركه
كبيره على الاسعار مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والامارات المتحده وكبار منتجي
الغاز مثل قطر على عدد من الاسواق
الاسيويه اذا الجانب الروسي بحاجه اكثر
ربما الى الجانب الصيني لكن ايضا الصين هي
بحاجه للجانب الغربي بموضوع مهم جدا وهو
ان
الاوروبيون الاوروبيين والامريكان يمكن ان
يتوجهوا الى الهند وهي قوه اقتصاديه صاعده
من اجل بخ استثمارات فيها
والاستعانه بالهند لكي تكون ان صح القول
معملا للعالم بعد ما لعبت الصين ضوء هذا
الدور لسنوات طويله الهند لديها عدد سكان
كبير يصل الى 1.4 مليار شخص هناك ايضا عدد
كبير من المهندسين وبنى تحتيه جاهزه
لاستقبال للاستثمارات الغربيه والصين لن
تغامر بخساره الاستثمارات الغربيه التي هي
استثمارات ماديه وهي استثمارات ايضا في
التقنيات العاليه التي ما زالت تحتاجها
الصين وهناك ايضا ازمه مهمه في الصين وهي
ان التنميه غير متوازنه بين المناطق
الداخليه والمناطق الجانبيه
الصين بحاجه لاوروبا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اكثر روسيا بحاجه الى الصين
اكثر بكثير في هذه المعادله طيب خطر وكان
طيب واضح الان ان التحالف او التوازنات
التقليديه تباعثرت وكان هناك دفع نحو
اعاده صياغه توا جديده في المنطقه تبع كل
العالم تغير بعد هذه الحرب نحن الان امام
معادلات جديده
واذا كان الكلام الروسي والصيني يتكلم عن
نهايه الهيمنه الامريكيه او السعي لنهايه
النظام الاحادي
ولو ان البعض في اوروبا ومنهم فرنسا تتكلم
كثيرا منذ ايام شراك عن عالم متعدد
الاقطاب لكن لا تزال واشنطن تقول انها
القوه الاستثنائيه التي لا غنى للعالم
عنها
حتى اشعار اخر تعمل على انها القوه العظمى
الوحيده في هذه المعادله لما قاله الاستاذ
سامر مهم جدا حول المقاربه الاقتصاديه
وهنا سؤال كبير هل الاقتصاد هو الذي يقرر
ام السياسه ام الاستراتيجيه ام المصالح
كلها متشابك في نهايه المطاف يعني في
اللحظه الاخيره وبالرغم من عقوبات ترام
الصين وبالرغم من عقوبات ايضا قاسيه فرضها
بيض بخصوص الرقائق الالكترونيه لاننا امام
عصر الثوره الرقميه وهذه وهذه هي المجابهه
حول تايوان لان التايوان اول منتج للرقائق
الالكترونيه اذا عندنا تايوان ومساله
التطور التقني الالكتروني عندنا مساله
كوريا الشماليه
المناطيض وما جرى حولها مساله اوكرانيا
اذا سيبقى هناك هذا الترابط الاقتصادي لكن
ضمن مجابهه وستحاول الولايات المتحده قدر
الامكان
التخفيف من الصعود الصيني التخفيف من
الصعود الاقتصادي الصيني هل يتم ذلك مع
الهند الهند مثلا تلعب لعبه حياديه هي نعم
في بريكس وهي في في ليس في شانكاي وتحاول
ان تكون مع هذه الدول ولكن في نفس الوقت
الهند عندما التقى رئيس الوزراء الهندي
بالرئيس الروسي كان اول طلب له ايقاف
الحرب اذا حتى الصين لها مصلحه بايقاف
الحرب من هنا
انا افسر ان كل هذا الضغط الامريكي بان
الى هو من اجل ان تطرح الصين تسويه معقوله
للنزاع الاوكراني لانه في نهايه المطاف
رغم كل الخطاب العالي هناك مازق يجب يوما
من الايام يعني بعد اسابيع من الان الى
شهر يونيو حزيران القادم يجب العوده الى
طاوله التفاوض وهنا باب القصيد الصين غير
ملتصقه بروسيا لكن الصين لن تتخلى عن
روسيا ولن تقبل بهزيمه روسيا هذا هذه هي
المعادله بتقديري واذا اقتنع بيض بالذات
لان اللعبه محصوره بين شخصين يعني بين
بوتين وبيدن يعني مع الاحترام لكل
اللاعبين الاخرين اذا اقتنع بايدن اقتنعت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بمنح بوتين
مخرج حتى اللحظه
قتل يوم بايدن الى هناك وبالطبع الزياره
متفق عليها يعني من الناحيه الامنيه على
الارجل
الموضوع هو الاتي هل يكون هناك تعقل من
الجانبين هل يكون هناك تعقل من جانب
الرئيس الروسي لانه هو الذي قام بالغزو
لحصر اهدافه ولكي لا تكون اهدافه مطاطه
ولاضاح مواقفه وهل يكون هناك من جانب
الولايات المتحده
سعي نحو تسويه ماء والا والا هذا الصراع
باستنزافه سينهك الجميع والصين كما كل هذه
الدول الصاعده ليس لها مصلحه تكلمت
المحاوره الكريمه عن سنه 2035 اذا الصين
لا تريد لتخطيطها ان يتوقف ولكن الان
عندما يتكلم جنرال الامريكي عن حرب مع
الصين خلال القادمتين لا استهتر بها كذا
كلام اذا هناك طبول حرب تقرع رغم كل شيء
ضمنها كذا مجابهه عالميه ومن هنا الاولويه
الان في كل هذه المناورات عند الوصول الى
نقطه توازن في الميدان كيف يتم الجلوس الى
طاوله التفاوض وموقف الصين في هذا الموضوع
مهم جدا بالنسبه للعربيه طيب تحليل المهمه
جدا سعاد بيشين ما رايك بالاضافه الى ما
قاله خطار ابو دياب يعني وكان هناك ادراك
من قبل القوى العظمى الان وفي طبيعتها
الولايات المتحده ان الاوضاع مؤخرا فيروس
كورونا وبعد ذلك الحرب في اوكرانيا كل هذه
العوامل انهكت العديد من الاقتصاديات في
اوروبا وايضا في الدول الصاعده في فتره
معينه البرازيل وما الى ذلك والان المساله
اصبحت مساله تنافس بين قطبين القطب الصيني
الذي يحاول ان يجند طبعا رو سيا الى جانبه
والقطب الامريكي الذي يقود
السفينه الاخرى هي السفينه الاوروبيه
والسفينه الغربيه
اعتقد انس زينه يعني بهذا الشان قد اكدت
فيه مختلفين للمناسبات انها تلتزم ببناء
مصير المشتركه لكل البشريه يعني هي تلتزم
بحزم
بتعدديه وتعرض سياسات القوه والحيبانه
يعني تعارض القطن وحادي الجانب واعتقد ان
السيده تعمل على
لم تعارض روسيا عندما حاولت فرض الامر
الواقع في اوكرانيا على سبيل المثال
استخدمت القوه في اوكرانيا
انا منذ بدايه اندلاعي حدث صراع العسكري
بين روسيا واوكرانيا اكدت السين موقفها
تجاه هذا يعني اول يجب علينا ان نحترم كل
سياده الوطنيه لكل دوله من الدول العالم
في اطار الامم المتحده هذا يعني مبدا
الاساسي ولكن يجب علينا ان نلاحظ او نهتم
ايضا بالمشا خلال المشتركه لكل جانب من
الجانبين ويمكن ان نلاحظ ان ما هو سبب
لتسبب هذه الازمه كان هناك يعني توسع
المتواصل لحلف الناتو شارقا وهذا يعني
يؤدي الى القلق من من روسيا
لتهديد في في حدود فرح حدود لها واعتقد ان
يعني ان السيده قد اعرب
اكدت في اكد تحده النقطه في ادلاء حدث
الصراع فاكدت السيده انها يعني تقف في
موقف الحيادي وايضا يعني تلعب دورا بناء
دائما في تسويه السياسيه لحاله اثبت او
كراي اوكرانيا ودعمت وتحافظ دائما على
اتصالات وثيقه مع كل جانب من الجانبين
روسي ولا اوكراني كما نعرف ان
الدبلوماسي الصيني
البارزاق
هذه الايام
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني واكدت واكد مجدد
موقف سيدنا تجاهها حالي السالمي لاسمه
اوكرانيا ايضا وايضا
هذه الايام طرح اكد ان سيدنا يطرح تسويه
سياسيه جديده لحل هذه الازمه واعتقد هذا
هو المساهمات الصينيه في حال هذه الازمه
سامر الياس تعقيبا على ما قاله ختار ابو
دياب يعني ربما محاوله الضغط على الصين
حتى تلعب دورا لان الولايات المتحده لم
يعد لها ما تفعل مع روسيا وبالتالي يمكن
ان تعول على الصين في ايجاد تسويه للحرب
في اوكرانيا هل تعتقد ان يعني حجم تاثير
الصين على روسيا بلغ الى هذا الحد ويمكن
لبوتين ان يقتنع به لاغراض اقتصاديه
واستراتيجيه
يعني مع احترامي الشديد لراي استاذنا
الدكتور خطار ابو دياب انا لا اتفق معه
تماما في هذا الموضوع انا اجد بان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لها مصلحه
باستمرار هذه الحرب ونظرا لانها
لكن الى متى تماما هي حتى الان المستفيد
الاساسي من هذه الحرب كما قلت واتفق تماما
بانها استطاعت بيع غازها باسعار اكبر هي
استطاعت ايضا كشف مواطن الضعف لدى الاسلحه
الروسيه هي استطاعت نملمه الاوضاع وعوده
الناتو قوه اساسيه بعد الانسحاب الفوضوي
من افغانستان في اغسطس عام 2021 استطاعت
عوده اللحمه بين طرفي الاطلسي بين اوروبا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه واستطاعت
ايضا ان تعود الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
قوه اساسيه في العالم الجانب الصيني ربما
في البدايات كنا نردد بانه سيكون المستفيد
الاساسي نظرا لان هناك تجربه مجانيه في
موضوع تايوان وفيما اذا اراد الصين تكرار
التجربه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا في لذلك في تايوان وجدنا بان
الرد الغربي كان سريعا متناسقا انا اعتقد
بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي
بالاساس تنفست السعداء
وربما كانت من اكبر المستفيدين والمرحبين
بخطوه بوتين باستياح اوكرانيا في 24
فبراير لانها ترى بانه يمكن ان يغوص بوتين
في مستنقع
اوكراني يشبه المستنقع الذي غاص به
الاتحاد السوفيتي في
افغانستان في
السبعينيات القرن الماضي الجانب الصيني
اعتقد تماما بانه جاد وراغب في ان يكون
هناك تجربه في تسويه سلميه للصراع لكن
الرئيس الذي مربوطين امام مازق كبير تم زج
به من قبل الفئات القوميه
والنخب القوميه في روسيا
ولم يعد لديه مجال كبير من اجل المناوره
والعوده الى الوراء خاصه بعد 30 سبتمبر
عندما اعلن ضم اربع مقاطعات الى الاتحاد
الروسي ونحن نعلم بان هناك تعديلات
دستوريه هامه كان قد بوتين دعا اليها هي
اكبر بكثير من موضوع ان الزواج بين رجل
وامراه والقيم التقليديه هناك بند كان مهم
بانه لا يجوز لاي رئيس في روسيا الاتحاديه
او اي هيئه برلمانيه التراجع عن اي اراضي
من روسيا الاتحاديه ومنحى الاستقلال ما
يعني بان بوتين ذهب الى الامام بانه لن
يتراجع عن هدفه في ضم الدنباس دانيت وايضا
وخريسون ايضا اي تسويه سياسيه الان من دون
ان تقوم روسيا بالسيطره بشكل كامل على
دانيتسكو
وخلصون
هذا يعني خساره للرئيس الذي في العام
المقبل يجب ان يحدد فيما اذا كان سيبقى
رئيسا لروسيا او يحدد خليفه وايضا هذه
الحرب سوف تحدد كيف سيذكر التاريخ الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين وهو المغرم بهذا التاريخ
والذي قال منذ اكثر من شهر بانه حقق ما
عجزت عنه يكثرين الثانيه
بطرس الاكبر معلمه وملهمه في حملات التوسع
شمالا وشنوبا طيب يعني انا اقول انا على
العكس انا اوافق
على ما قاله سامر
من زاويه اخرى
العامل الشخصي نعم عند بوتين كما عنده
بايدن سيلعب دورا كبيرا كيف سيدخل التاريخ
من خلال البوابه الاوكرانيه لكن لا يمكننا
ابدا مقارنه متصل اكبر وكاترين مع بوتين
لانه في النهايه ايضا التاريخ علمنا ان
روسيا دائما تكسب عندما تدافع عن نفسها ان
كان بوجه نابليون او بوجه هتلر لكن عندما
تهاجم لا تربح ولذلك الان في اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا نعم المازق كامل المازق حتى الان
كامل بمعنى
السيطره على مقاطعات الاربع عندما نرى ما
يجري في باخمت
بخمط شبيهه ببردان ما بين فرنسا والمانيا
يعني حرب تدميريه مع عشرات الضحايا يوميا
اذا هذه الحرب مكلفه جدا للجانبين وايضا
حول مستقبل روسيا يعني عندما يقول بالامس
قدروف
الزعيم الشيشاني انه سيؤسس شركه حربيه مثل
شركه يعني روسيا التي يقول بوتين انه يحرص
على عدم تفكيكها لكن الان ماذا جرى للجيش
الروسي اذا دخلت
خط اذا هناك منطقه والمشكله حتى بالنسبه
للغربيين يعني المازق ايضا من الغربيين
يعني هذه يا حرب هجينه يعني حرب من القرن
التاسع عشر وقال القرن العشرين والقرن
الحادي والعشرين حرب اقتصاديه حرب
سيبرانيه حرب حول الطاقه الامن الغذائي كل
شيء يعني تصوروا ان كل مخازن
مصانع الاسلحه في بلدان الناتو ليس
بامكانها تامين الذخائر للجبهه الاوكرانيه
الى حد ان الى حد ان هذه الدول اضطرت الان
للتعاون مع استراليا مع الهند مع دول اخرى
من اجل ايجاد مخارج اذا هذا هو مازق لانه
الى السؤال الى متى يمكن لبوتين ان يضحي
بشبابه والى متى يمكن لاوروبا والولايات
المتحده ان تدعم اوكرانيا كما تدعمها
اليوم بالرغم من كل الحماس يعني نصف مليار
دولار اليوم قدمها بايدن لذلك المساله
ليست هذا اليوم يعني ليس هذا اليوم
المطلوب للتسويه الصينيه ان تمر او لتسويه
ربما الصينيه فرنسيه سعوديه لماذا لا يعني
يمكن ان يكون هناك عده اطراف تلعب ادوارا
ايجابيه في هذا الموضوع قادر على التكلم
مع الطرفين لكن هذا كله سيتوقف على ماذا
على ما اسميه نقطه توازن في لحظه ما سيدرك
كما سيدرك زيلينسكي ومن يدعم زيلينسكي انه
لابد من تجميد النزاع
الخطر في الامر انه يمكن ان يجمد النزاع
كما النزاع الكوري والحرب الكوريه كما
نلاحظ مستمره منذ الخمسينات الارجح هو مع
الاسف تجويد النزاع تجميد الخطوط ولكن
حرب الاستنزاف يجب ان تتوقف في لحظه ما
والا ستتحول لصراع عالمي خطير جدا وعند
ذلك يمكن ان نتكلم عن حرب واسعه ولهذا اظن
ان بقاء دول مثل الصين مثل الهند ودول
اساسيه لها ثق لها الاقتصادي وهذا يلعب
دورا كبيرا نعم سيؤثر بشكل او باخر على
الرئيس بوتين في خياراته طيب سامر الياس
ربما لك اجوبه على اسئله خطر ابو دياب
لا انا اعتقد بان الجانب الصيني هو قادر
على التاثير على القرار الروسي بكل تاكيد
العامل الاخر الذي كان مصدر خوف ربما
بالنسبه للعالم هو تطور الصراع الى حرب
نوويه نظرا لان الطرفين يملكان روسيا
والناتو ويملكان قنابل نوويه ورؤوس نوويه
كبيره فيه الفتره القليله الماضيه
بالمناسبه كان هناك حديث روسي عن موضوع
القنبله القدره كل التحليلات قال جانب
الروسي كان قد حذر من ان اوكرانيا يمكن ان
تفجر قنبله قديره في عدد من الاماكن في
خرسون او في زبالوجيا وتتهم روسيا بانها
قامت بذلك هناك بعض الخبراء الوازينين في
المعادله الروسيه يقولون بان روسيا حذرت
من هذا الموضوع نظرا لان هو كان هناك قرار
روسي باستخدام القنبله النوويه في
اوكرانيا ولكن لم تكتيكيا ولكن لم يكن
هناك ثقه بان الاسلحه النوويه الموجوده
لدى روسيا وعددها نحو 5 اسنوي يمكن ان
تعمل بالشكل الطبيعي نظرا لان صيانه هذه
المعدات بحاجه الى اموال ضخمه ولم تخضع لي
عمليات تحديث وتجديد منذ اكثر من 30 عاما
منذ انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق
الجانب الروسي يعاني من موضوع الاسلحه
ايضا كما يعاني الجانب الغربي الذخائر
التي كانت تطلقها روسيا بشكل كثيف في
الاونه الاخيره تراجع عددها هناك مشكله
حقيقيه اليوم الى ونحن على ابواب
بالمناسبه الذكرى السنويه لتاسيس الجيش
السوفيتي لسوره الجيش السوفيتي الذي اذا
اذا تكلم اي مواطن روسي عن اي خساره لهذا
الجيش الروسي فانه سوف يسج به بالسجن ست
سنوات بينما ينتقد مقاتلون فاجنر وقديره
الجنرالات الجيش الروسي وبالامس كان هناك
مقاطع فيديو لعناصر من فاجنر يصوبون
اسلحتهم ضد الكسندر لابين
المنطقه الوسطى الروسيه التي رفعه بوتين
منذ فتره قائدا لاركان القوات البريه
ورئيس الامكان
المشكله الان باننا ربما وصلنا الى نقطه
صعبه تشبه
نقص الذخائر الذي كان في الحرب العالميه
الاولى عندما كانت هذه المشكله اساسيه
الكل يبحث عن مخرج لكن اعتقد بان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه حتى الان لم لم تكمل
فائدتها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تدفع
مبالغ زهيده جدا من اجل
كسر روسيا وهزيمتها وتبيان مواطن الضعف
لدى الجيش الروسي وايضا من اجل تعريتها
سياسيا اقتصاديا اضعافها وحتى اخلاقيا عبر
المطالبات من
بنكن في الاونه الاخيره بان هناك محاسنات
للجانب الروسي طيب هو يبدو ان الصين شخصت
الوضع كما يجب الوضع العالمي هل الصين
برايك تريد ان تكون طرفا مساهما في وضع
مواصفات النظام العالمي الجديد
اولا يمكن ان نلاحظ ان السيناد تسعه دائما
الى يعني تعزيز التعاون والتعامل بين
مختلف الدول العالم كما اكدت السيده يعني
اكد زعيم الصيني
بناء المسير المشترك لكل البشريه واعتقد
هذا هو يعني سياسات الصينيه الخارجيه
الدائمه في هذا يمكن يعني ان نلاحظ ان
السينا تعارض سياسات القوه وهيماذا وتلتزم
بالتعدديه وايضا يمكن ان نلاحظ ان الصين
تساهم وتقادم مساهماتها في
حقيقه تنميه المشتركه لكل دول العالم وكما
مثل ما ذكره
ومي في تقرير في كلمه الذي القاه في مؤتمر
ميونيخ للامن امرا انا يعني سنه ثائلات
عقيقه يعني توازن
وتحقيقه تنميه المشتركه لكل الدول العالم
ليس
هذا العالم هو هو خلل في هو خلل وهو خلل
خلل في ساعود اليكم
الان هو انا ما نلاحظه هو الترذيل دور
مجلس الامن ودور الامم المتحده منذ بدات
هذه الحرب
لم يلعب اي دور وكان الجميع سعيد بذلك
الامن الدوله بالاساس هو اداه
للتعطيل يعني بمعنى عندما تقرر دوله عظمى
دوله من الكبار ان تفرض حق النقد يعطل
مجلس الامن ولذلك يتم اللجوء الى الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده ويتم اخذ بعض
القرارات لكن في النهايه نعم الاء بيد ان
الامم المتحده لعبت دورا مثلا بمساعده
التركيه في موضوع ازمه الحبوب واتفاق
الحبوب وهذا شيء ايجابي هذه هي امكانياتها
يعني مجلس الامن خاضع
لميزان الوفاق الدولي الاهم انه يعني عن
اي نظام دوله جديد نتكلم المشكله اننا
امام فوضى استراتيجيه هذا هو الخلل الكبير
اي نحن في مخاض
الولايات المتحده تريد ان تستمر بنظام ما
بعد الحرب البارده وما بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه لانها هي من تقود وتتحكم بهذا
النظام الملك الدولار صندوق النقد الدولي
البنك الدولي كل المؤسسات الناتو حلف شمال
الاطلسي الاتحاد الاوروبي همش اين يمكن ان
يكون هناك امكانيه ضمن هذا المخاض ببناء
نظام دوري جديد اذا كان من صعود لاقطاب
اقليميه فاعله وابرزها القطب الاوروبي
القطب الاوروبي غائب يعني بريطانيا خرجت
من اوروبا المانيا انانيه بمعنى ان
المانيا كانت من قبل تعتمد على الغطاء
العسكري الامريكي وتعتمد على العلاقه
الاقتصاديه الاستراتيجيه مع روسيا وهي
تمرر مصالحها وهي قوه اقتصاديه الان
المانيا استفقت قررت ان تخصص الاموال ولكن
بدلا من ان يكون الدفاع اوروبي مثلا في
الدفاع المضاد ذهبوا لعند اسرائيل
والولايات المتحده وليس لعند فرنسا او
ايطاليا ليعملوا سويا كل هذا يدلل على
الهشاشه الاوروبيه
استغله الولايات المتحده اذا ضمن شروط
نشاه نظام عالميعادل تعددي ان يكون هناك
قطب اوروبي لانه يمكن ان يكون عامل توازن
حتى لا تصبح القطبيه الثلاثيه لانه نحن
امام قطبيه ثنائيه لكن في حال تحالف الصين
مع روسيا سيكون هناك قطبيه ثلاثيه عند ذلك
يمكن ان يقود ذلك لمزيد من الصراعات هل
هناك مصلحه عند الجميع في انتاج مصانع
الاسلحه للكثير من السلاح والمزيد من
الصراعات اظن عندما نرى الزلازل يوم نرى
الاوبئه نرى التغير المناخي يجب ان يكون
هناك عنايه بالانسان يجب ان نفكر
اقل بالطموحات
وبامكانيات هذه الدوله والتلك ونفكر
بالمستقبل المشترك بشكل اخر وهذا لم يحصل
حتى الان سامر الياس يعني عندما يتعلق
الامر بمصالح يمكن ان توجد عنايه بالانسان
باختصار لان في نهايه البرنامج لا اعتقد
ذلك انا اتفق تماما باننا امام انتهاء
النظام العالمي
القديم الذي ساد بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه بعد انتهاء الحرب البارده ولكن
اليوم نحن امام بلاد صعب ربما لنظام عالمي
جديد روسيا كانت من الاطراف المؤهله لان
تكون طرفا في بناء نظام عالمي جديد ولكن
حربها الى اوكرانيا اضافتها بشكل كبير
مصالح الانسان بطبيعه الحال هي الغائب
الاساسي ربما عن جميع المخططات السياسيه
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وفي روسيا
وفي الصين انا اريد ان اختم ربما بموضوع
يتعلق
بالمهاجرين او اللاجئين الاوكرانيين
الموجودين في الدنمارك هنا اعرف العشرات
منهم هم من الناطقين باللغه الروسيه ولكن
وهم من اصول روسيا ولكن حتى الان هم
يحقدون بشكل كبير على بوتين لا يريدون
بشكل او باخر ان تحكمهم روسيا رغم ان
اتنيتهم روسيه وحديثهم في بيوتهم باللغه
الروسيه بوتين ادعى بانه يريد حمايه هؤلاء
ولكن في المقابل هو شردهم موافقتهم كل شيء
فيس وغيرها من المناطق التي تعرضت للقصف
الانسان للاسف هو الغائب الكبير في كل
المعادلات السياسيه التي تقوم في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وفي روسيا الشكر في
الختام من بكير لسعاد بايشين
لسامر الياس كاتب وصحفي مختص بشان الروسي
والشكر طبعا في الاستوديو لخطر ابو دياب
استاذ في العلاقات الدوريه شكرا لطريق
البرنامج امسيه مريحه للجميع
[موسيقى]